three two
one
welcome back everybody to another
episode of trendy versus traditional
we'll be cooking two different versions
of your favorite classics for today's
episode we will be making
hot dogs
i don't know how much wiggle room for
trendy traditional hot dogs there is it
will be a more convenient way to eat hot
dogs let's put it that way i want to let
you know i've got some tricks up my
sleeve today to try and set me apart i'm
looking forward to it see in a couple of
minutes hours days i don't know i gotta
get out of here
good luck thank you
i have my apron on and my hair tied i'm
ready to make some trendy hot dogs it's
once again a street food item from south
korea they're very good at creating
trends recently this type of hot dog
it's called kamjao hot dog which is
basically essentially potato hot dog
think of like a corn dog but it has this
like potato chunky coating on the
outside and i have yet to try one so i
figured i'd make it myself folks i've
been tasked with tackling the
traditional hot dog but it's not just
going to be a heated up hot dog in a bun
today we are going to be making a chili
cheese dog i have eaten an embarrassing
amount of chili cheese dogs the amount
of times i've sat on the trunk of my car
just absolutely slamming down a foot
long chili cheese dog you would lose
sleep over it let's get into it i have
to make this batter that is going to
have to rest for an hour so over here
you can see this beautiful puffed up
situation is basically just water sugar
and some active dry yeast and i already
started off here and in this other bowl
i'm going to add some flour
and salt so i'm going to combine this
yeast in here i'm using a rice paddle
because i'm following maangchi's recipe
and she uses a rice paddle so i'm using
a rice paddle so once we have that in
here i'm just going to mix it together
she said mix for two minutes this is how
i make my base level chili it's killer
on a hot dog and i feel good about this
so first i'm just gonna get this
jalapeno a little prepped here you may
notice i'm like making it nice putting
it into glass bowls and i have a theory
inca beats me a lot in this series and i
think it's because she does a good job
of laying out her ingredients and gets
the lay of the land so i could dump a
can of beans into this pot i could just
take some chicken stock out of the box
and pour it in but we're keeping it
professional here okay i'm trying to
level the playing field this is my bread
for the hot dog i don't know what buns
chris are you using but i'm assuming it
will be
you know
the buns at your local diner what
i didn't say anything i don't want
anyone coming for me in the comments
about how i'm chopping the garlic how
i'm prepping my little mison plats
is it funny to all of you that i make a
mess
it's already feeling even better so i'm
gonna stop now i'm going to saran wrap
this and set it aside wait for an hour
in the meantime i can prepare my
potatoes which will be the coating all
right gang in goes our base for the
chili here
while the vegetables are sauteing i'm
just gonna hit them
with a good sprinkle of salt we're just
looking for our vegetables to soften a
little bit relax and then we're gonna
start our next steps of the chili here
okay so my batter it's actually right
down here
and in the meantime even before i skewer
the hot dogs i'm going to make my little
potato coating so i'm going to start by
just peeling these our vegetables have
been going for a little bit they look
nice and soft so i'm gonna kill the heat
real quick smells really good
folks the beef's going in we're adding
beef on beef it's getting wild here i am
going to cut these now into like little
cube shapes you don't want them too
small
but you don't want them too big either
maybe that's a little too big that's a
little too small it's a little thick oh
there we go that's better i'm gonna put
them in this bowl for now the ones that
pass the test it's probably the slowest
way to cut potatoes
gosh break up the beef my twitter handle
by the way if you want to follow me it's
at underscored the real break up the
beef it's not my twitter handle but it
should be give that a couple stirs real
quick i'm going to season in a sec
anyone who thinks oh he's putting
unseasoned beef in here is it going to
be unseasoned no
enough
people aren't talking enough about salt
salt is good it makes everything taste
better i don't know the science behind
it but i know the taste behind it
water's boiling i am going to now toss
don't do that i'm going to toss these in
peps and beef reuniting at last
in go the peps and the garlic give these
a stir together
so i'm gonna go start with half of this
tomato puree here give that a stir
kind of just evenly coating everything
then
my favorite part
the beans
[Music]
no chili is complete without some beans
all the ingredients should be on the
tinier side we don't want big chunky
chili which is my instagram handle if
you want to follow me this is just to
help remove that excess starch just
giving it a good stir
look at how cute they are little potato
chunks
all right so now i have to strain these
again i'll be right back be right back
one of the final steps we're going to
add some chicken stock here to just
loosen up the chili a little bit our
chicken stock is just to make the chili
a little more liquidy kind of ideal for
ladling across a hot hot dog it's
important to always carry a tasting
spoon in your pocket i swear i've had
that the entire time you can go back and
look at the footage maybe it's there
maybe it's not irrelevant
i'm feeling good feeling good about that
we're popping a lid on this
the beans are gonna soak up all the
juice it's gonna thicken up a little bit
then we're just gonna jump right into
the hot dog and assemble this bad boy so
i have my potatoes here i strained them
again and i dried them basically just
like dabbed at them a lot with the
kitchen towel i'm gonna coat them with
flour to make them even drier and
crispier this is not part of the
original recipe but i wanted to add a
little bit of seasoning to it for more
flavor so this is just white pepper
cayenne pepper and paprika because i'm
assuming that chris is
flavoring up his hot dog so i i don't
want to lose out okay that's pretty good
and over here i'm just gonna skewer my
hot dogs so i'm going with chopsticks
instead of skewers because
this is a very heavy hot dog i figured
this would be a little stronger a little
sturdier so i'm just going to
poke into it
i have my hot dogs prepped i have my
potatoes
batter is pretty much done now so
i'm gonna reset the table set up my
station and we're ready to fry this up
very excited very excited folks we did
it the chili is done i'm gonna toss a
lid on to keep it nice and warm
all right take it easy there's a new pan
coming
i'm going to toss
a hot dog in a pan we're gonna crank the
heat up to to like a medium medium-high
this is probably going to get everybody
going nuts in the comments do you boil a
hot dog do you grill a hot dog do you
see her a hot dog everybody's got a lot
of dog chatter
that's all you in the comments going
wild for the dogs i can smell the hot
oil i think i'm getting pretty excited
welcome to my little street food stall
okay look at this look at this dough it
has totally risen you ready you ready
this is amazing this is what's going to
coat my hot dog so i'm going to go right
in with my hot dog now i'm going to let
you know how i do this going to put a
little bit of water
in here probably like 2 tablespoons or
so
you toss the lid on
you let the dog kind of steam soak up
all the water inside there then once all
the water is evaporated you pop the lid
off the dog gets seared it's the best of
both worlds i hear a little crackling
coming out of the pan here all the water
is evaporated and here is where the hot
dog just springs to life it's jumping
out of the pan just scoop it on there i
saw what she did that was helpful was to
twirl it so she also did say you can go
in with your hands if you need to okay i
know it looks a little crazy right now
it's all part of the plan i promise
i washed my hands
i promise so next i'm going to put this
in the potato and just glue the potato
on i should have put more batter oh it's
a little crazy right now no she made it
look so simple but it's not that's a lot
of potatoes on here right now so i'm
just going to put it in the panko now
which i was going to season with salt
and pepper but i have completely
forgotten
i should have seasoned my panko
beforehand but here we are i just want
to say this is what it looks like before
this is what it is now if i fail i have
three more sausages it's fine this is it
it all boils down to this moment right
here out of nowhere i'm gonna produce
this beautiful potato bun look how
pretty this is i did not bake this this
dog is barking to get out of this panel
our hot dogs done i had a phrase in my
head of hot dog blisters not a good
phrase but that's the reality of what
we're looking at here this is the type
of dog we're looking for so step one
dog in
bun now we're gonna do a little bit of
chili here chili's been cooling off to
the side here we don't want to drown it
in chili the chili is just there to like
raise up the hot dog it's there to
elevate the hot dog i don't know if
anyone's ever used the phrase elevate
with a chili cheese dog but i'm going
there oh my god it's going to come apart
i just know it's going to come apart
seven minutes hold on where's my phone
ah it is going crazy right now oh oh
okay maybe my oil is a little hot but
honestly
get a little scoop of our our chili here
i'm gonna try and get a good amount of
the juice out of the spoon here chili's
going on it's okay if it spills a little
bit out of the sides that's what we're
going for i have tongs now like a
professional my corn dog is huge i hope
our judge is hungry because the ones i
see on the trees are like so cute and
friendly this is like intimidating ingo
always has a secret weapon there's
always just like a little extra sprinkle
of something special on the top i was
hiding this processed melted beautiful
cheese behind the chili the entire time
and you had no idea this is just melted
cheese a little queso we action i think
this is what's going to set my chili
cheese dog apart and likely give me the
win here going on we're just going to do
a little little drizzle action here i
feel
pretty good
about this dog there is a minute left on
this and i just realized the reason
my hot dog is so big is because in the
original recipe that she actually only
makes half of this sausage that's why
it's like a nice portion what have i
just created
let me show you what i mean by big hot
dog okay
it looks so good just sitting here i can
make others for our judge but i gotta
take a bite of this one this is actually
seasoned with
sugar kind of like that sweet and savory
combination we're talking about a little
bit of salt as well a drizzle of ketchup
a drizzle of mustard and that's it
that's my trendy hot dog oh boy it's a
monster
it's great oh god it's so good i picture
myself at a baseball game it's saturday
night i'm slamming chili cheese dogs i
eat so many of them that i make myself
sick this is gonna win i know it i don't
even know how to eat this gosh okay
pretty good actually it's pretty good oh
my god that crisp was
and um it's like fried and hot dog i
think i might be a little more generous
with the ketchup and mustard a little
more sugar maybe but i'm feeling good
chef's kiss okay
i'm ready
[Music]
three two one
oh
[Applause]
no not again
what do you say we just settle this the
old-fashioned way and bring in a
resident hot dog appreciator let's bring
him in
where is here
[Music]
i think i'm so excited yes i'm super
excited to be whoa what do we have here
double glizzy action
challenge baby oh my god i'm super
excited we're gonna go traditional first
and we're gonna see what's going on
super traditional like i would say it
even tastes like one of these like new
york water dogs that we get from the
street in the corner what have you but
then just with some awesome high quality
toppings and that awesome can cheese or
whatever off the top that's just bang
bang and slide this guy over and now
this even has a carry stick i honestly
don't even know where to start so
oh wow i think it's so good
yo
this is it
it's awesome because it's crispy but
then the potato got mushy enough on the
outside to like coat the glizzy the hot
dog everything's super tasty the
official result of the test
trendy's going to win today
i'm so sorry i have a feeling that's
where this was going thank you i really
appreciate your biting ability it was a
pleasure as always awesome youtube
always a pleasure
vic out i really was not expecting to
win the way he attacked that hot dog on
a stick i knew right then and there it
was game over for me okay go
dogs on deck
yeah i lose
i lose okay
that's it for trendy versus traditional
hot dog in the comments what do you want
to see next otherwise we will see you in
the next episode
[Music]
you